hello and welcome everyone to yet
another
tech enthusiastic video from simply
learn today
we will learn about java enterprise
edition
before we begin i would like to let you
know guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies
if you wish to stay updated then please
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon
so that you can never miss an update
from our end now without further ado
let's quickly dive into the agenda for
today's discussion
so first we will understand the
definition of java enterprise edition
followed by that we will understand why
exactly we needed java enterprise
edition
and then we will get to know the
specifications of java enterprise
edition
followed by that we will understand the
system requirements
you need for running java enterprise
edition in your local system
and followed by that we will have a
briefing about how to set up the java
enterprise edition into your local
system
and finally we will wind up the session
by learning the basic differences
between
java standard edition which we normally
use and the java enterprise edition
which is used by the professional for
enterprise purposes
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's quickly begin with our
first topic
now let's quickly begin with our first
topic that is
what exactly is java enterprise edition
the java ee stands for java enterprise
edition
which was earlier known as j2ee and is
currently known as jar kataka
ee the java enterprise edition
provides a platform for developers with
enterprise features
such as distributed computing and web
services
now let's move further and understand
why exactly we needed
java enterprise edition we needed java
enterprise edition for
four major reasons to have powerful api
support
to reduce development time to reduce
application complexity and finally
to improve the application performance
so followed by the need for java
enterprise edition
we will move ahead and understand the
java enterprise specifications
so in the java enterprise specifications
we are going to discuss
the four major specifications used by
enterprise
developers so the first one being the
enterprise specification
followed by that we have a web
specification then we have
web server specification and finally
some other miscellaneous specifications
we shall discuss each one of them in
detail firstly
we will move ahead with enterprise
specification
so in enterprise specification we have
the first one to discuss
that is the context dependency injection
the context dependency injection
provides a container
to inject dependencies as in swing
next we have java enterprise java bean
the enterprise java bin is a set of
lightweight apis
that an object container possesses in
order to provide transactions
remote procedure calls and concurrency
control
followed by javabean we have java
persistent apis
so the java persistent api are the
specifications of
object relational mapping between
relational database tables and
java classes next we have the java
transaction api
it consists of java interfaces and
annotations
to establish interaction between java
transaction support
offered by java enterprise edition the
api is in the abstract from
low level detail to the interfaces are
also considered as
low level followed by java transaction
api
we have the java servlet the java
servlet specifications define
how you can manage http requests either
in a synchronous or
asynchronous way so followed by java
transaction api which is one of the
enterprise specifications
we will move ahead into the java web
specifications
so the first one in the java web
specification is the java servlet
so this specification defines how you
can manage the http request either in
asynchronous or
asynchronous way it is low level and
other specifications completely depend
on it
so followed by java servlet we have the
java web socket
so the java web socket is a computer
communication protocol
and this api provides a set of apis to
facilitate
web socket connections followed by
websocket we have the java server faces
so the java server faces is a service
which helps in building graphical user
interface
out of the components so followed by
java server faces we have
the unified expression language the
unified expression language is a simple
language
which was designed to facilitate web
application developers
so followed by the web specification now
we will enter
the web server specification out of
which we have the first one
which is a restful web service so the
java restful api
web service provides services having
representational state transfer schema
next we have the json processing
java api for json processing is a set of
specifications to manage the information
provided
in a json format followed by json
processing we have json binding
so the java api for json binding is a
set of specifications that provide for
binding or
parsing a json file into java classes
next we have the xml binding so xml
binding simply allows for binding of xml
into java objects
for example soap is an xml-based
protocol
to access web services over http this
api allows you to create
soap web services so followed by the web
service specifications of java
enterprise edition
we finally enter into the other
miscellaneous specifications of
java enterprise edition sort of that the
first one is
the validation so the validation package
consists of various interfaces and
annotations for declarative validation
support offered by
bean validation api in java followed by
validation
we have the patch applications so the
batch applications provide
the means to run long-running background
tasks which
involve large volume of data and which
need to be periodically executed
followed by batch applications we have
java enterprise connector architecture
so the java enterprise edition connector
is a java based technological solution
for connecting
java service to enterprise information
system
so with this we will enter into our next
step
where we will learn the system
requirements to install java enterprise
edition
so the basic requirements to install
java enterprise edition into your local
system are
you should be having the java virtual
machine from the standard 6 edition or
more followed by that your local system
should be having
at least 1 gb of ram capacity
next your system should be having at
least 250 gb
rom space available and finally you
should be having the java development
kit installed into your local system
now next we will understand how to
install java enterprise edition into
your local system
so in short these are the steps you need
to follow to install
java enterprise edition into your local
system first
you need to browse into the oracle
official java site
then go to java standard edition
development kit
followed by that accept the license
terms download the jdk file
run the jdk file as an administrator in
your local system
then set up the java environment i know
this looks a little bit complex but
don't worry
i will drop a link in the description
box below which will explain you in a
much detailed way
how to install java into your local
system please check that to have a
better understanding of
how to install and set up java in your
local system
so followed by this we will learn the
differences between
the java standard edition and java
enterprise edition
so the first difference between the
standard edition and the enterprise
edition is
the standard edition provides basic
functionalities like defining classes
and objects
whereas java enterprise edition mainly
focuses on
high-end and corporate type of java
applications
the second difference between the both
is java standard edition
comes with only the standard
specifications which will be used by a
beginner
and similarly on the other hand java
enterprise edition comes with some
advanced specifications which support
web applications and servlets
the third difference between the both is
the java standard edition
comes with features like class libraries
and deployment environments
whereas the java enterprise edition has
structured
application with the clients business
and enterprise layers
the fourth difference between the both
is
the java standard edition is used for
desktop and mobile application
developments
whereas on the other hand the java
enterprise edition is used
mainly for development of web
applications
the fifth the difference between the
both is the java standard edition is
preferred and used by
beginners and on the other hand the java
enterprise edition is preferred and used
by experts in java field
the sixth difference between the both is
the java standard edition does not have
authentication
whereas on the other hand there are
strict rules and regulations to be
followed when using java enterprise
edition
related to authentication so with this
we have come to an end of this
particular tutorial
if you have any queries related to this
particular video or
any questions related to java then
please feel free to drop them down in
the comment section below
and we will have your questions answered
as early as possible
till then thank you until next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here